>>> THIS IS "CNN TONIGHT."
K SOR JOININWHATEVER YOU'RE G,N
AT HOM
H THIS AND YOU M BE
FALLG P IN THEI NT S
YY ORWH
.I T FIT FOR YOUR RIGHT TO VOTE.
CLOSE TO HER LIKE ?G A
>>O WHAT RIGHT THERE YOU'RE HEN
GEA ENTATIVE
NOE ESTED ANVED FROM TR KNOCN
DURING GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP'SING,
INSTED TO  YOUR VOTE
SOCIED T HERE IN MOMENTSCANNON
IS LED AWAAL OFFWITH HER H
HI
RYE CE
REMEMBER, SHE IS A
REPRESENTATIVE
>> SHE'S NOT UNDER ARREST.
UNDER ARREST FORHA
OUHERS THERE
DEMANDING, DEMANDING THAT
OFFICERS NOT ARREST HER.
SO I JUST WANT Y TH THIS
SHE'S CT REPRESENTATIVE
THAT IS BEING REMOVEAS
GOVERNOR IS SIGNINTH
>> WHY ARE YOU ARRES HERHY HER?.
RESTINHEWHE VIOLATION.
CITE T
WHAT IE  "N    VIOLATION OFODE.
CITE IT.
THE CODE.ODE.
WHY ARE YOU ARRESTING HER?
UNDER WHAT?
>>, MA'A.
GE WAY.
>> UNDER WHAW STING HER?
>> THAT'S WHATU. ARRESTING HER?
>> LET HER G
WHY ARE
>> STO TELL USOWWHY ARE YOU ARR?
TEREASON WHY YOUREARRESTING HEVY
ARER?
!
>> SHE IS AN ELEENTATIVE.
WHY ARE YOU ARRESTING HER? STAT
ARRESTING R WHATTUE GOVERNOR IW
WILL AFFECT ANS ANN CIAL>> HOW?
TR Y
EMOTION AROUND IT.
TH.U OUTRAG?
THGR
EPG
SOURCES ONHAHERE
GHREOUCE.
WHT, INCLUDING
POLI.
RE THA TO KEEP AN ELECTED REPRE
NO
PLE IN
KEG A BILL N
THATAMOTG FOOD OR WATER TOWA
ALLOWING UNLIMITED R STE TO REF
IS ABOUT NOTHINGAYHT T
VOTE.ITSI.ATS VERNOR, PROUD  S .
WHY WEREN'D TO SIGAT AIL MEN TH.
THD HNEWTSHNHE
FIRST ONE OUT THERE FIGHTING
AGAINST THIS
THE BILL THE GEDT ACO E GH
WHOSS
AND TONIGHT GOVERNOR KP IS
TA H.PILLARS OUR DEACAND IT IS N
THSTATE THAT HELPED JOE BIDEWHI
THAT GAVE CR.ENCE AT ICITF COLO.
PRESIDENT JOE
PASSIONATE IN HIS FIRS
COER TUT
RICANS, THE RIGHT AIINST VOTER
SUPPEFFORTS, CALLING
THEM SICK AND UN-AMECAOW-AMERI
INITIATIVE IS.IT'S SICK.DECIDINU
CARING W
TI
VOTE?DE GOIEND VOTING AT 5:00 W
WORK?E ARE JUST
DITHERE WILL BOSUMSTANCES? IS R,
MONTHS NOW WHADE
IT IS PLAIN  HATE -- IJUST -- I
YOO.OU
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
IT IS BUILT ON A LIET OPLE
OFORS
COUNTR TID
AICIALSSLATORCI IT
MET TON  L ABOUT THE ELECTION.L.
U LIED TO THEM
. WHY THA
NC.NGS A LIE ON
OFN LI
LL TAX WITH A DIFFERENT NA